all right we have a new Star Wars
trailer why do I look so tired
i I woke up hours ago and I was like
okay by the time the trailer drops I'll
look awake
it's that didn't happen whatever we have
a new trailer to the rise of Skywalker
some are calling it the final trailer to
the rise of Skywalker which wouldn't you
really think about it means this is the
final trailer of a course Star Wars
movie that will ever get ever I mean if
this movie's the end of the Skywalker
saga at the very least it means this is
the final trailer of any movie
pertaining to the Skywalker saga that we
will ever see taking one last look sir
my friend
okay I'm gonna dress that [ __ ] no Abrams
if you kill 3pl [ __ ] now you already
brought Lando back no so now we're all
convinced he's gonna die just don't kill
the droids they're the soul so basically
this trailer starts out it's like oh
great she's training that's good that's
how you're supposed to get good I do
hope force ghost Lucas training Rey as a
Jedi because Luke training Rey should
happen that's so important this whole
[ __ ] it just seems to be the natural
course of things Luke should be training
Rey but if force ghost Luke is training
Rey I feel like if Luke had lived past
the last Jedi Luke would still be
training right so the scenario is Luke
lives past episode eight and trains Rey
or Luke dies in Episode eight and still
trains right so if he was gonna train
Rey anyway why kill him so it looks like
you see the resistance it's grown in
numbers because probably Rea because she
keeps saying people keep saying they
know me
it looks like raised social media in
this world in his universes it's gotten
pretty out there
great shot with kylo Ren though that's
some good [ __ ] it does have some good
moments that I do like like that one
line in this trailer with Luke I
[Music]
completely agree Luke absolutely
positively that is a factual statement
about a Jedi all right I'm gonna overlay
the two and I'm just gonna see what it
looks like so the emperor has this big
stone throne he's like for so long I've
waited for you I've craved you I've
missed you out of the ice but alright
can we talk about how bad guys always
have the worst chairs ever Palpatine's
new throne looks uncomfortable
Diana's throne looks uncomfortable I
would never sit in these chairs point is
bad guys have the worst gamer chairs
ever but you do see the sight of
Palpatine's Club also you remember in
the matrix when neo said guns and we
need lots of guns
it's like JJ was like ships I'm gonna
need lots of [ __ ] it doesn't make it
feel like yeah it's because it's the
last chapter of the last chapter I just
hope they don't go the route of light
alright we're just gonna throw a lot of
ships and [ __ ] on screen because you
know makes it feel bigger it's last
chapter but everything needs a point in
purpose it's just don't do it just
because also what's that [ __ ] is that an
illusion are they working together now
does someone get dust with carbonite and
those two just shatter them I'll tell
you what I thought of hasta la vista
baby what anything about this trailer
which isn't a surprise because JJ Abrams
makes vague trailers but this trailers
very vague which worked for Star Trek
because I was intrigued just because of
a new Star Trek movie it looks all
modern and all right let's check it out
works for Star Wars Episode seven
because the new Star Wars movie has Star
Wars is back baby I don't need to know
anything about to know I'm excited too
let's go watch it I don't know if this
movie has you know apply like if you
look at the prequel trailers I feel like
you still knew more about the plots of
the pregel's we all knew they were
making clones out of a bounty hunter
named Jango Fett and to menace we knew
like the core of it was an invasion of
Naboo Revenge of the Sith Vader
we all knew and
in turn innovators so they just showed
that it goes from what I can ascertain
from the trailer what I know about this
movie is Threepio is having a big speech
about seeing his friends for the last
time but we all know he's downloading
porn into his neural net she still wants
that Kyle O'Day Palpatine's back and
everyone has a metric [ __ ] Tilian number
of ships that's what I know about this
movie I don't want the trailers to show
too much but for this trailer in
particular I could have gone for a
little more plot of alright what's
driving this whole thing forward I don't
go into this movie optimistic if not
curious I want to see how it ends you
know cautiously optimistic basically how
I went into solo but if I'm going in
with a hope it's that it's better than
solo first of the new and possibly last
trailer to Star Wars the rise of
Skywalker have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you'd like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
say more
[Music]